like everyone so for this last section
of the day very happy to have centers
with us about your talk with inter on
the convergence of Hamiltonian okay so
this talk is about the sampling problem
which is to generate a random point
according to non-negative integral
function the density is proportional to
that so this has many guises and special
cases of interest such as sampling from
a convex body or some density restricted
to a body and so on yes so one case that
may be prototypical to keep in mind is
sampling a point from the uniform
distribution on a given convex set this
itself already has two settings in which
you could talk about it one the set is
given by an Oracle so you can ask in or
out and you have a starting point in the
set alternatively it's explicit it's
just a polytope this stock will mostly
focus on the second setting I'll just
point out how it compares to the general
setting whatever we mentioned why do we
want to work on this problem it seems to
really address some questions in
optimization even though it's not for
let's say the most practical situations
the fastest algorithm given just these
two settings you know what's the what
are the limits and abilities of this
these more computational models and then
you can compute a bunch of things which
we don't know how to do by other means
such as computing the volume the center
of gravity the covariance of a
distribution and so on you can do some
certain extensions of optimization by
this that we don't know how to do by
other means such as robust or noisy up
when there's noise in the in the data or
in the objective stochastic optimization
exploring models for for in machine
learning and then I guess perhaps most
most of all it provides a different
angle on how to think about convexity
did to just take one more slide do this
there is this general intuition that a
problem is easy if it is written as a
convex problem at least it's polynomial
time up to some approximation and
randomization and maybe the other way
around is true in some sense I don't
know what sense but here is the sequence
of convex problems right that's solving
linear systems when you're programming
convex programming and sampling block
concave functions and you know the
complexities of these for convenience
I'm taking em order n in the a part here
so that's matrix multiplication time
that's that's into the 2.5 because of
interior point but square root n you
know with this reset foot barrier and
then using cutting planes you get n cube
for general convex programming and
sampling is n to the 6 it's really
hidden in here is n to the 4 steps but
each step takes n squared but that's
that's this general picture now you
might ask where is this going F is
convex you know maybe maybe we can do
everything in N squared and then even if
you wanted to solve linear systems you
could just sample that's the this might
not happen this year yeah ok so sampling
polytopes this is the problem we'll
stick to M constraints and variables you
want to pick a uniform point in K this
is what we know about this problem we
can do it in n to the 4 iterations where
each iteration takes M n time all the
algorithms are just Markov chains and so
I'm going to tell you how many steps of
the chain and how much each each step
takes then for polytopes
so this this is general works for any
convex body but for polytopes canada
rinin in 2009 analyzed what's called the
deacon walk which i think in this
audience might be familiar to many
because it's based on the dickin
ellipsoid defined by a convex barrier
function in
case just the logarithmic barrier and
then the number of iterations for a
polytope with f assets is only MN and
the time per iteration is MN to the so
this is matrix multiplication time m n
to the Omega minus 1 last year
within that we had an improvement on
this brief briefly mention it where the
complexity goes down below quadratic
which so far seems to be a bottleneck
for the other methods with the same per
iteration time in order try to mention
today is what we think is the right
generalization of the previous approach
and it gives us a slightly better
complexity this is what we can prove for
all we know there's no m and or n I'll
tell you in a minute
and the first step complexity is MN to
the 1.38 now this is all in theory in
experiments that when I think he might
even be doing them right now but it's
it's here's a comparison coordinate hit
and run which is an implementation of
hit and run that seems to be comparable
in in in performance and faster in first
step complexity instead of MN it's only
M per step amortized it takes about N
squared steps this Hamiltonian process
that I'll describe in this talk seems to
take a constant number of steps and each
step is solving a linear system which
basically takes the same amount of time
right now so yeah sampling might be down
to the complexity of you know poly
logarithmic number of linear system
solves if this becomes a theorem but
this is empirical this part
okay so that's for sampling one note
what the application of sampling is
volume and for volume there's been a
bunch of progress or using various
techniques so using the general for the
in the general setting volume or
integration you can do it in n to the
four steps these are a number of steps
again each step in the general setting
of course depends just number of Oracle
calls but when we talk about polytopes
again each step is is is going to be
this matrix multiplication time and the
total complexity of computing the volume
is down to MN to the two-thirds it's the
same complexity as sampling so this as
far as I know is the first improvement
for volume computation we're using
polytope structure lets you beat the
general case and you know quite a bit so
that's that's sort of an application so
in this talk what i'd like to cover is
the limitations of traveling on straight
lines Hamiltonian dynamics and this and
this walk we can call the ham walk
convergence of this process the role of
iso perimetry in this convergence and
what we can prove and not prove and this
how we do volume are using this in this
new setting in this general thing okay
so just to build up to this to this to
this to this process how do we sample so
we use random walks as i mentioned and
the first one of the nice ones with a
essentially complete analysis is the
ball walk which says for a current point
in the body you pick a uniform point in
a little ball of fixed radius Delta so
is a parameter Delta if the point is in
the body you go there otherwise you try
again so that's the process now it's
symmetric you know the probability of A
to B is the same as B to a it's just 1
over the volume of the ball so the
stationary distribution is as we want
and now the question is how many steps
each step is a membership right so if it
were a polytope it would take order MN
and so the theorem for for convergence
is that it's polynomial in the dimension
the diameter and how how close is the
starting distribution to the target
uniform distribution in particular let's
say that this this distance is a
constant as measured as a ratio then the
result of Condon lavas and Shivan ovens
from 97 already says that the number of
steps you need is N squared d squared we
can arrange D this is for general bodies
for isotropic bodies which means that
the covariance matrix is the identity
and the diameter might be n but most of
the bodies in a ball of radius square
root n its n to the 2.5 and for if the
if the current of a streamers hyperplane
conjecture is true and I briefly
mentioned this at the end then the
complexity would be n squared so this is
the status of the ball walk each step
for a polytope would be MN now there's a
limitation you could ask why are we you
know N squared is what is order N
squared can you do better the answer is
no and even in a hypercube it can't mix
any faster and the reason is that the
step sizes are severely limited if you
if you try to make your step size any
larger than what it is set to be which
is 1 over root n then the probability of
stepping out becomes too large it just
starts its explores exponentially so you
can't afford to make scale up your step
size and therefore because of diameter
which you take you have this problem ok
hit-and-run is the the other process
that's been analyzed and is practical in
it this one has no parameter Delta at a
point you pick a random direction and
chord through it and then a uniform
point on that interval continue so at
every step you're actually making a step
this is also symmetric no probability if
you go A to B B to a the density is the
same and so the Cession distribution is
as we want
there is no rejection filter needed but
it has the same problem you know this
picture is misleading what actually
happens is that the
cards fight 500 to pick in my body a
random point it's very likely near the
boundary and then I pick a random card
it's very likely going to be pretty
short about basically the length of the
step that we were taking with the wall
walk 1 over root n on average so it has
basically the same limitation even
though you don't need to worry about
these worst-case issues of getting stuck
suddenly so in both cases you have this
N squared lower bar and that is a lower
bound this process can't be any faster
due to the boundary even for a hypercube
now this D can walk that I mentioned
that Conner Narayan an introduced or
analyzed does the following it says why
should I take the same steps from the
same ball each time or from the same
distribution if I were doing hit a hit
and run
I should adapt the local distribution
according to where I am in the body in
particular if I'm in the main city to
the body let's take a big ball if I'm
closer to the boundary let's take a
smaller ball so the way they do it is
you know there's a matrix a which is
basically given by determined by the
slacks of the current point again I
understand they've been reading groups
on interior point methods but but but
for a point you're looking at how far
every boundary is and that's giving you
defining an ellipsoid and so this
ellipsoid will be completely contained
inside the body for no matter which
point you are but it will get smaller
and smaller as you get closer to a
boundary so we pick uniformly from side
this ellipsoid and and and go there
except you'd be careful since these
ellipsoids are no longer of the same
volume we to make the process to go to
the right distribution we have to apply
a filtering step a metropolis filter
which is basically the ratio of where
you are to where you might go and that
way you ensure the uniform distribution
so nice as it is and this has one very
nice property which is that it's a fine
invariant now so which scalings of the
original body don't matter you don't
have to do any rounding you might that's
nice you can't afford to make these
ellipsoids too large because then the
ratios of the volumes will go crazy you
still need to keep them keep them on it
so that that leads to this MN bound even
from a warm start and
limitation again is this rejection
probability if you make them larger you
run into this issue okay now in place of
the deccan walk where the ellipsoid is
defined by what's called the logarithmic
barrier the the Hessian of the
logarithmic value you could use other
barriers I mean there's a whole theory
of inter point methods you could use
other barriers and in some nice recent
work Chen the Reddy Wainwright and new
are considered for example the
volumetric barrier why the Earth's
interior point method and they get it's
still going to be quadratic for m equal
to n but they get for example one of the
results is square root m times n to the
three-halves and the first step
complexity will of course go up
depending on what interior point
function you are computing okay so this
is this this is the status here so we go
back and ask you know how does this
actually happen in let's say nature you
know that would be Brownian motion no
yes we want to make the step size is
larger let's do the opposite and make
them infinitesimally small
so that would be Brownian motion now of
course and that's that that you know
that's the heat equation the way it
dissipates but what do we do when we
have boundaries and we have to come up
with something this is again the whole
field partial differential equations and
studying these things but you know
people you can reflect you can have
other boundary conditions if you do
reflection we run into very similar
issues now the idea would be let's try
to do bound motion and do reflection at
the boundary
once again you'll have to use very small
step sizes when you discretize in order
to maintain your target stationary
distribution okay so that doesn't quite
work the other option is just remove the
boundary let's let's get rid of the
boundary what does that mean we still
want to have a distribution so one way
to do it is to use a barrier function
let's write this in more detail so you
can take a polytope and map it to what
you might call a hessian manifold and
what is that instead of you thinking of
points the distance between points or
the the length of a point as just being
the Euclidean length there's a different
metric at each point like the ellipsoids
we had at each point
there's a different metric it just
measures the length according to the
local ellipsoid well why ellipsoid
because it's going to be the Hessian of
a convex function
that's why session 1 so so when I equip
the sway space with such a such a convex
function and therefore a hessian at
every point that's the that's the
hessian manifold we're talking about ok
so each point has its own ellipsoid now
for a polytope and and this is the only
barrier function we're using the stock
the standard barrier you could imagine
following a situation here is the
polytope that's the function so those
are the level sets of the function and
then for each boundary hyperplane
there's a slack
which measures the distance so those are
the slacks and this function blows up of
course as you get close to any one of
them and that's your that's your
manifold in this sense we remove the
boundary so we will travel will be
traveling effectively on this so you
might give you can go forever but on in
the real space it moves very slowly as
you get closer to the boundary now if
you do have to be careful if you did
things uniformly here then you'll spend
most of your time near the boundaries
and we want to be uniform so we'll have
a deterministic field that pushes us
away from the boundary it's a rejection
there will be deterministic field that
pushes you away so this is the process
think of the continuous process first
its Brownian motion which would have
been just this plus drift just pushing
you in a direction designed to make the
target the stationary distribution
uniform or whatever it is that you want
and each step is this Gaussian
infinitesimal Gaussian but chosen
according to the local metric so
whatever is your local metric that tells
you what the next Gaussian is ok so
that's this general process everywhere
you have a little little ellipsoid
you'll make a step according to that but
there's also a field that's pushing you
away from the boundary when there is no
determinism I mean don't no drift and
and it's just uniform everywhere that's
the standard heat equation and now when
we generalize with drift and general
metric can we get a faster method
so then to do that we have to choose
what metric to use and and the drift
presumably will be completely determined
by the choice of stationary distribution
but we still need to choose what metric
we get this big choice the one we
analyze is the metric defined by Hessian
sometimes because it's it's it's worked
well in optimization and something we
have some idea how to analyze but it's
an open question as to what's the best
metric or how to choose the right metric
so in this case this this this
differential equation becomes the
following here is the Hessian to the
minus half and there's the drift and the
drift is completely determined by this
also it looks like this just by solving
the corresponding differential equation
and so here you have the Hessian inverse
times the gradient of this of the log of
the determinant of the hessian that's
the that's the drift so the point is
that you get an explicit equation for
each where you know what the
differential equation is at each point
now the question is can we discretize
this and get a faster method and that's
that's what leads to this process called
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo the Hamiltonian
in case like me you don't remember it
from physics is this really elegant way
of expressing Newtonian mechanics that
just says one function that expresses
both your kinetic and potential energy
and motion is a is a process that
maintains this laws of motion are just
maintaining this so what our Hamiltonian
dynamics is this Hamiltonian H suppose
function of position and velocity and
you get to look at the that the change
in the position is a derivative the
Hamiltonian with respect to the velocity
and the change in velocity is a negative
of this the point of setting up these
equations this way is that when you move
according to these things quantity H is
maintained don't change and so that's
the Hamiltonian walk at current point X
pick a random velocity how do you pick
the random velocity according to the
current distribution defined by X the
cording to the local metric so a
Gaussian with that covariance matrix and
then you move along the curve no longer
straight lines these are curves defined
by this Hamiltonian in the direction we
for sometime delta or minus delta just
to symmetrize everything so that's the
process now this process came up in
practice first I first learned about it
at a Simon's workshop we last may that
co-organized and it's already being used
in machine learning widely to sample
models to take because other other other
metropolis filter based methods for non
convex problems were too slow in
exploration
the earliest reference we know is Dwayne
Kennedy Pendleton Rowe at 87 where they
used it in to analyze some quantum
mechanics and then Neil in 96 started
applying to various statistical
inference problems including sampling
neural network models and then this was
extended to this general setting that
I'm describing it in where you have you
have different metrics at every position
by your Alami caldo head and chin and
there's many many references if you just
google Hamilton in Monte Carlo you'll
see it's used quite a bit given at least
four talks in that workshop about okay
so this is the setup so the sample now
let's say if more generally I want a
sample according to this Gibbs
distribution you know exponential in
some convex function and I get to choose
the metric G so at each point X G of X
is this matrix then I set up this
Hamiltonian and this Hamiltonian if I
run this process is maintained and then
if I sample on the margin for X I get
the right distribution e to the minus f
of X so these are all sort of lemma 1
and lemma 2 for this process well
understood that's why they use it in
practice use this Hamiltonian run it for
a while and then sample the marginal on
X so you pick according to the metric at
the current distribution and then you
move in the direction in the in the
random direction we either plus Delta or
minus dealt with your differential
equation so so you know you have this
drift term that's what you're running
and now we're going to discretize this
that's the Delta part of it this is the
the equation that's telling you how to
move and the only discover ization is
how long we should move before we pick
the random velocity again the drift
preserves this Hamiltonian which you can
think of as the total energy the process
is symmetric and there's no filtering
there's no rejection probability at all
okay so what constraints analysis why
not just write one run one step
things are changing of course the
advantage is that rather than straight
lines which will hit boundaries quickly
these things are going on curves which
never had the boundary in fact the this
Hamiltonian preserving quantity curves
around it just goes and comes back and
you know show you a little picture what
we can prove is that for a longer time
then you could have done with previous
walks into the one fourth time the you
stay away from the boundaries if you're
at some distance from the boundary it
takes you that long to even have your
distance we were able to go quite a
while before before things get unstable
for this week this is a you might
recognize this type of properties it is
useful if you've worked in optimization
if you could for example prove such a
property for the central path defined by
some objective function a linear
objection then you would get a faster
max flow algorithm because this the
number of steps would be fewer but of
course what we're doing here is four
random directions not for worst case
directions so convergence we have some
general theorems which you assume
smoothness of the function and the
metric and a trigger constant and tell
you what the convergence rate will be I
won't put them up for the log barrier in
a polytope this is the bound and then to
the two-third steps for a hypercube
it's just poly logarithmic all the other
previous methods take at least n steps
even for hypercube of course you know
how to sample hypercube in in log n
steps anyway but but you can do it this
way yeah
what is the so one question is what's
the best metrics to use I don't know
then another question which will
elaborate on in the remaining time is
what's the corresponding isoparametric
conjecture in this manifold
setting so what we can prove and this is
the core of how we get the sampling
theorems yes yes yes exactly that's why
I put it in parentheses you know suppose
I don't worry about one step computation
complexity still it's interesting to
know what's the optimal metric I mean
somebody told me maybe you threw in that
that Einstein color is is a very good
one but I don't know what it means to be
optimal or yeah it would be nice to or
the kinetic of that yeah yeah yeah so I
think even for theory purposes even
knowing what's the rate without worrying
about implementation would be
interesting yeah so here's the surface
the core isoparametric theorem that that
goes into this I have this poly tope and
I've made a partition into three subsets
and there's a distance between any two
points but the distance is not Euclidean
distance it's the distance defined by
the by the metric right so there's a
local metric so you integrate along
along all curves and that gives you the
minimum among all curves that's your
distance then what you can say is that
for any alpha you can think of alpha as
one if you like the integral of this s
s1 and s2 are separated by distance D
then the integral of s3 is at least the
smaller of s1 and s2 times the distance
times square root alpha okay this is
optimal is the best best you can prove
for such a metric up to constant it's
optimal that this just means is a hidden
constant and and it's actually a special
case of this is something previously
known if you take 5x to be x squared so
it's like a Gaussian restricted to some
polytope and the distance to be
Euclidean distance then that's a known
special case of the careless conjecture
when you have a Gaussian restricted to a
polytope and for that we know that this
this was already known so for this
general setting when we have want a
sample Gibbs distributions like this
the with the log barrier you get this
complexity when alpha is about 1 over m
that's uniform sampling essentially
that's why you get m n to the 2/3 but if
alpha is higher there actually it's
faster if you want a sample more skewed
distribution it's much faster and will
take heavy advantage of that in the
volume algorithm ok so that's what it
looks like in 2d in I do have to say how
you very quickly how it is that we
actually implement there is a running
program so it can be implemented but you
have to solve this this differential
equation at each step how do we know
that that you know how do we solve this
or how do we know that we can guaranteed
solution quickly the point is that these
functions this the the the solution to
this and functions are smooth enough
that in fact they can be approximated by
low degree polynomials and in previous
paper we showed that as long as the
solution is low degree we can find a
good approximation very quickly in
essentially linear time the number of
evaluations of the function without ever
computing a derivative which would
involve a gradient will involve a huge
matrix and slow things down so the
running time is is n D times D is the
degree of the approximation for us it's
or tilde that's that that's what it
takes to solve it okay I will I think
I'm running out of time so I'm gonna
very quickly just so we can use this
process now to get a faster algorithm
for volume and the volume algorithm is
essentially the one from work with Ben
cousins where we did it for standard
volume improver and cube for well
rounded bodies but now we apply that
algorithm in the setting of manifolds
these Hessian manifolds and we're able
to go at a rate that is determined by
this self concordance parameter which in
the case of the log barrier is M and
so that the total time is M n to the 2/3
over epsilon squared over there for the
entire algorithm I do more than that but
let me conclude this is the last slide
with this question so the the careless
conjecture and says that if I take say a
convex body or in the case of poly tope
I take a polytope and I look at the
subset that minimizes its boundary
compared to its volume or that of its
complement so what's the minimum [ __ ]
cut you know the the the the cut that
minimizes the ratio of the boundary to
the set or its complement the conjecture
says that it's within a constant factor
of what you can get with a hyperplane a
hyperplane minimizer is the minimum up
to a universal constant factor you could
ask is something similar true and I'm
only saying question nor conjecture is
something similar true if instead of
using Euclidean distance we use distance
according to a hessian manifold and a
polytope and I it should be false should
be wildly false but I don't know a
counter example
[Applause]
so you defined the diffusion is it it's
not obvious but yes it's it's true the
diffusion is changing the drift at every
point it's imagine you're picking the
direction in which you'll move as well
as the at every point here we are
keeping the the direction the same for a
while so depends how you mean
discretization but if I say time
discretization with respect to Che when
you change the the the Gaussian the the
random choice of direction
then yes
[Applause]